[Music]
[Applause]
we know
more about surface of mars than we do
about what's under the ice sheet in
[Music]
antarctica
[Applause]
my name is john prisky and i'm a
professor at montana state university
my research focuses in polar regions so
i've spent about seven years of my life
on the ice since i started working in
antarctica in 1984
we transform our whole way of thinking
about the continent it's not just this
benign
block of ice anymore it's a living part
of our ecosystem
my first time i went to antarctica it
was in 1984
as i flew down in this military ski
plane and looked out the little oval
window my first glimpse of the continent
as far as you can see
it was just solid white
antarctica is the fifth largest
continent it's about one and a half
times the size united states
and it just struck me that it cannot be
devoid of life
you can't have that much real estate on
earth
that's not alive at that time i started
studying
microorganisms people didn't believe
that there were microbes in ice
and that kind of compelled me to prove
them wrong a little bit
the lake boss stock that i call the gem
of antarctica because
it's one of the largest lakes on our
planet it's been ice covered for
15 million years and we were able to get
some
ice from the russian drilling project
and
we showed that there was a living
ecosystem in solid ice
we'll see and we'll figure out how deep
the lake is
firstly it's really exciting because you
don't know what's down there
we're not even sure if there's a lake
down there a water body
we used a hot water drill where we
melted the glacial ice
[Music]
we were the first ones to drill through
the antarctic ice sheet into a
sub-glacial water body
i'll never forget the moment when we
broke through into a lake
and you could hear the cheers you can
hear the cheers through the whole field
camp
[Music]
as a scientist in any field you always
want to make a breakthrough
we're finding life where we never
thought it would be
for 15 years i was writing review papers
based on
circumstantial evidence that antarctica
was alive and i was having troubles
getting them into journals and finally
when we broke through
it changed the entire way we think about
that continent
and it changed my life for sure
[Music]
in antarctica i actually crossed paths
with a few nasa scientists
and we talked about how these antarctic
systems could be analog for what we were
seeing on mars
and then through the ensuing years as i
was learning more
about life in solid ice and
under ice and in complete darkness it
made
a lot of sense there would be life
beyond earth
planets now have habitable zones similar
to what we would see in the in
an antarctic or a greenland situation
actually this month we're going to send
up the mars 2020 rover
to collect cores and then set them on
the surface of mars
and then within the next decade the plan
is to send another
rover up to retrieve them we'd be in
denial
honestly you know based on the
scientific evidence
what we we know on earth about the
niches for life and the habitability on
earth
and what we're learning by the day of
habitability of of extraterrestrial
worlds
so i'm a believer
you